this morning in our school matters
series a Texas school found the perfect
formula to improve test scores a math
teacher decided to use music videos to
engage his students his efforts helped
turn around the Leadership Academy at
Como Elementary in Fort Worth Texas just
a few years ago he was considered a
failing school
Revier we all went there to find out how
it found its rhythm Hamish Mayfield is
willing to do just about anything for
his students Mayfield has been teaching
math at the Leadership Academy at Como
elementary for a year a school in a
predominantly black neighborhood where
the median family income is less than 19
thousand dollars and more than 94
percent of the students are economically
disadvantaged the reputation is seen
from outside goers would be a crime
those socioeconomic families I'm
single-parent homes instead of what
before may feel came on board the school
was at rock-bottom attendance was low
disciplinary action high and their test
scores were so bad they'd received an F
rating by the state if you do not get
out of that hole then yes the state can
decide to come in and take over your
schools you guys were on the verge we
were knocking on that door principal
Valencia Rides was brought in to fix the
problem my mom was a single parent of
four I had a father who was in and out
of prison most of my life I realize now
that my mom would go to bed hungry so
that we can eat and so I'm able to
understand where a lot of my kids come
from and more importantly I'm able to
hold them accountable to not using any
of those things as an excuse to not try
to do better for yourself
recognizing the hardships Como students
face disguise Reince news they needed
joy
part of creating that joy included
recruiting Mayfield the kids can work
and they could do for you and they can
do for themselves but you have to show
that you're transparent to be able to
connect with them on other levels
outside of just being in the academic
setting may feel calculated by adding
students and fellow teachers together in
music videos he could help kids love
what they were learning there was a song
that we first saw with Andre kind of
song I know way too many numbers here
right now that I didn't know back then
when you bust out like that yeah what's
the reaction you get from the kid mama
mama you know you know what Jackie
trying to be more like Oprah with the
best visit mansion to maybe old former
students jailer Williams and Daniel
Washington say his approach to math is
what made them want to come to school
every day hero fellas I've been through
this you can't get around with me like
that and because he made his learning
very for it we scratch on all of this
they become what principal rides also
credits adding an extra hour to each
school day and offering families more
after-school programs to Como's
transformation to sum it up we just got
the official results this morning we are
officially a B campus again this year
it's not hard work as hard work and I
feel like you have to come from the
heart in order to be able to do this job
of teaching a school that can say
they're starting on a high note for CBS
this morning midday OVA Allah what Worth
Texas for you Bravo como Leadership
Academy and mr. Mayfield and principal
Rimes number when I was a kid you
weren't even supposed to move in your
chair right mr. forget E in algebra he's
got a C maybe if I had mr. Mayfield I
don't remember the details just fine but
just the fact that he believes that
learning is fun that makes learning fun
for the kids and you always always joy
always works the way that he can figure
out a way to do that and Robbo
it just takes one person leaving you to
validate to see you matter I've been
there I can get through it I got through
it you can go through and did you hear
Maria said they actually go to school an
hour longer and no one seems to be
complaining about that mmm mr. Mayfield
go you